Dr House is out of control but so am I
let's watch this episode
we've got into an accident along the
canal road just outside Kingston
are you hurt she should have asked that
she have a pulse and if not Sir Charles
compressions
you're not fine you have a metal object
going through your body
ow
can we hurry this up make sure they take
your time
[Music]
Hannah morventhal
you have super Hannah morgenthal what is
cipa oh I don't we have to do x-rays to
make sure you don't have internal
injuries blood tests to make sure no
infections EEG for neurological
anomalies and
biopsy a spinal nerve I love how he just
decided that because he didn't like how
she was responding to the alcohol on her
leg and first of all who puts alcohol on
a leg all you need is a little soapy
water like alcohol actually disrupts the
skin tissue there only been about 60
documented cases yeah and I have
seven reasons to think that she's one of
them or she has moralgia peresthetica
she's wearing a really tight belt come
on house Shape Up reason number one
she knew what it was without us telling
her that's true but she could have also
been just acting tough you know because
some guy challenged her like you too
she's still wet from the snow she's not
shivering that's odd unless You Can't
Sweat or feel hot and cold the ambulance
was warm
I want to see my mother three scarring
around the lips and tongue when she was
a baby she chewed on herself without
feeling it I fell through a window when
I was a kid four you clean the wound she
flexed into the cleaner instead of away
from it it's hard to fake pain when
you've never felt it takes an
imaginative leap Ms morgenthal she wants
to see her mom she admits having sea
fish she knows we're not letting her go
anywhere without a battery of tests if
she already knows she has sepa why run
the battery of tests I feel like house
just like wasting Hospital resources
taking her to see her mom
imagine he's wrong and he just said just
hit a poor kid
oh why am I laughing
okay sir one of those imaginary cases
that happen when you're bored sipa
zipper
diagnosis
diagnoses happen at the end of cases
thank you she's got no idea what's going
on in her body it's bound to be
something wrong in other words she could
be perfectly healthy but you're curious
about someone who can't feel pain
because you always feel pain so you want
to go exploring or maybe because she has
sepa and was just involved in a major
car accident you should pan scan her
make sure she doesn't have internal
bleeding or injuries which would be a
very simple test that house doesn't need
to be present for and he can go home she
was in a car accident
she's x-rays blood tests EEG nerve
biopsy what does she need an EEG for
what are you looking for if she's having
a seizure right now you can see if she's
having a seizure do your test except the
nerve biopsy you need the nerve you risk
paralyzing her what do you need a nerve
biopsy for I get it if it's congenital
we know there's no need looking for a
biopsy and a cause if the EEG reveals a
problem we can talk then but the EEG is
not a defining test EEG is going to show
you brain waves like what is that going
to tell you maybe they meant an EMG and
they're just using the wrong acronym
that's an EEG no idea why they're doing
it sparking on leads C3 and R2 you could
be going into a seizure
oh what is this I don't understand she
could be you can't see it what do you
want us to do hold her down
only until you inject her with a
sedative then you can let her go we
tried
seriously she's strong and doesn't care
we'd have broken something before we can
get her to sit still enough to inject
her so break her arm she won't mind
you're cranky I'm in pain and he's
jealous of her for not being in pain
little does he know a world without pain
is a much more dangerous and problematic
world than with pain
ironic every morning I have to check my
eyes to make sure I didn't scratch it
corny in my sleep oh God stop I'm in the
pool of Tears here I can't cry neither
can I every morning I check my eyes for
jaundice in case the vicodins finally
shot my liver I can't run anywhere
without examining all my toes for
swelling I can't run it's opposite ends
of the spectrum neither are good that's
why we have
homeostasis
I'm sick no your EEG was normal x-ray
showed no breaks blood test show no
infections urine indicated though
call code okay okay okay
you do not call a code because someone
becomes unresponsive she could be having
a seizure you don't need to call a code
a code is when someone's heart stops see
the ice packs and cooling blankets
for what
do you know what the condition is it's
not flush he's not sweating you must be
she's a temperature of 105. how does she
know oh because the thermometer was
still hanging on her mouth normally if
you are a healthy adult a fever will be
controlled if you have a rare condition
it can go out of control and actually
cause harm to your body that is why I am
a proponent of in certain instances
decreasing the amount of Tylenol Advil
Motrin that we give to patients when
they have a mild fever because a mild
fever generally speaking doesn't do harm
in fact it allows your immune system to
work better and fight off infections
make your symptoms go away faster
improve your immune system make you uh
spend less time being infectious
infecting other people so like in this
case this is the rare instance where her
fever can fire her brain what if
we give her more pain signals a lot more
pain signals maybe some of them will
make it through you want to torture her
no
yes we do this to anybody else it's
torture doing it to her is no different
than pricking her finger
we keep poking sharp sticks into her
eventually we'll find the part that's
already tender that's the most
ridiculous thing I ever heard of on the
off chance that maybe she might feel
something and maybe we'll poke the right
area what if it's internal what are you
gonna do then Chief is warm
the other
it's very hot
start here move to the hot one just a
few seconds then back we're going to
monitor activity in your brain while you
do it
if you feel any response to the Heat
could indicate a vascular problem
but tell me it's going okay you can take
your hand out and you didn't ask
anything else
take your hand out of the water what's
going on with my mother
second degree burns
because you put her arm in scalding
water
doctor I don't feel anything when you
guys screwed this thing into my head I'm
gonna replace missing chemicals in your
nerves heightened sensitivity
what on What planet this would never
happen
oh my God honestly I wish I was this
girl simply so I could sue this hospital
and become a billionaire judge jury they
drilled into my skull because maybe they
thought I'd feel it
I win that's it I win
so what I just said sure will you guys
drill a hole on me
just think about it if they drill like a
centimeter too deep and hurt her brain
and she becomes
functionally impaired
then what like they're pros and cons of
this are terrible
it's okay what you feel
where did you feel it
Anna I need to know how it hurt
what just happened I need you to go to
the nerve biopsy show never did it well
then do it can't why she's gonna jump
off the lobby balcony
you think I can catch her
house is an ass
but what did he expect house to do
like for real though like maybe call
security I don't know like what do you
want from us what do you want us to do
I can't feel my legs you're trying to
pull the same stunt twice in 10 minutes
I'm not pretending
[Music]
pretending
they couldn't have put something below
her so that if she did jump she would at
least have a padded surface
anything we're not looking for pain
anything at all pressure nothing
you have six broken bones a fever a
concussion erratic heart rhythms and a
complete lack of sensation below the
waist I feel fine
guilt
guilt
a symptom yeah I've never heard of that
Alzheimer's can cause Euphoria pain
causes depression and B12 deficiency
causes guilt maybe she had a B12
deficiency she would have been anemic
they would have seen that on the CBC
give her a shot of B12 if she gets
better I was right
or check her levels like I don't
understand I'm not happy
her white blood cell count was low the
ones she's got
so a lot of eosinophils hyacinophils
could be a worm a parasitic infection
is it possible for you to just watch me
eat
or do you get some primeval thrill out
of beating the other Hunters to the food
B12 deficiency are you having Deja Vu
we've had this conversation she was
given B12 she didn't get better oh maybe
she is lacks intrinsic factor to bind it
someone else ate it
get an abdominal MRI what
Ash has a word
15. you're not going to anesthetize her
relax it's just a magic trick
I'm just thinking
Lake fishing can be fun
it can bring the generations together
you know cook that trout or perch well
giving room and board to this fella
like Freeport I mean on B12 you could
take in a tapeworm essentially starts
feeding on the foods that you're
consuming so it literally takes away
nutrients from you most commonly you can
get a B12 deficiency but then you would
also get a resulting anemia which is why
this episode's a little confusing
because they said the CBC was normal
outside of a low white count
and five feet long damn it
World Records over 60. they didn't see
the tapeworm on all of the Imaging that
they did this girl's case is interesting
because she has this condition she
doesn't feel anything therefore she's
not aware of the tapeworm and that's not
unusual a lot of people won't be aware
of a tapeworm but because she has this
tapeworm was not getting B12 she
essentially started having neurologic
complications as well as having a fever
because of the infestation of the worm
and all these other symptoms popped up
but at the same time they didn't pop up
like they normally would in a healthy
individual her presentation was masked
because she has the conditioned sipa
detox tea is a scam click here to check
that out Wednesday checkup video it's a
throwback as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]